[Music]
first of all I was talking to Kevin Hart
recently and he was complaining to
borrow some money but Kevin Hart said he
we were talking about you and he said he
gets so frustrated he said I can't make
cube break I can't crack him up he tries
and tries and tries he shoots these
movies with you
he tries everything everything he can
think of the whole crew will be laughing
you with that face just staring you
don't break around right you don't break
what is it what is it about I mean Kevin
what you know are you doing it to be
mean to Kevin or he's just doesn't make
you laugh
well Kevin annoys me you know me it's
not funny
he annoys me so all I gotta do is think
about how much he annoys me man I don't
I don't break I don't crack and you know
I've worked with a lot of different
comedians you know I mean from Chris
Tucker to mic gaps to Traci more again
you know tracing one Get Well man and
you know I'm the ultimate straight man
you're not never crack because you not
think I owe it to the performer to to
let him do his thing
right yeah so during the course this
interview I will get you though you're
gonna completely lose it and giggle like
a schoolgirl
[Music]
it's gonna sneak up on you oh you ready
uh I just worry that you're very
depressed yeah anywhere you depress me
laugh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
knowing really I can't believe that did
you know Kevin Hart school the comedy
skills at kids birthday party around
two-year-old take you break my
three-year-old
Leto's kids alone all right